[Music]
[Applause]
a dein mccordi NBC football night in
America Studio analyst won three Super
Bowls with the Patriots three-time all
pro and uh it's Bill's Dolphins Sunday
night so the last game of the regular
season and a lot of playoff implications
there let's start with that one Deon
thanks for joining us um what do you
expect out of the Buffalo Bills and the
Miami Dolphins in that final game Sunday
night man I kind of expect a slugfest I
think it's always interesting as these
division games come down to who's going
to win the division we all have kind of
these preconceived notions from watching
the two teams but I feel like when it's
a divisional game nothing else matters
it all matters about that day so I think
you know Miami comes in a little banged
up on defense losing Bradley chub will
be big and I expect the the bills to try
to take advantage like getting James
Cook going again running Josh Allen a
little bit I know he had the Stinger so
have to see how he feels but I think
ultimately Miami should feel like
they're in good shape at home you've
played well now you have a chance to win
a division like you kind of LED All
Season you want to go put your best foot
for and I think it'll have to come from
their offense Sunday night but you know
the Dolphins entertain me but I don't
know how good they are all season long I
still don't know do you I don't and I
think for them they have to try to find
that confidence and that edge to say
like hey I know what we are it's been up
and down we've only beaten one good team
in Dallas and Dallas's you know record
on the road has in pretty bad this year
but now if we just go beat Buffalo we
can play a home game we win the division
we can do everything that's in front of
us but if they get stuck on all the
narratives of what they haven't done I
think they can you know that'll put them
in trouble Sunday night when you get
blown out now this is the team that blew
out Denver scoring 70 and then the
Ravens we're kind of piling on on a
little bit um how does that feel as as a
professional you know do you if you're
in Miami are you taking offense that you
know the Ravens are still throwing the
football while they're up you know by
four
touchdowns I mean you can but you you
shouldn't because if if you don't want
them to do it stop it um but I think
it's different I think for San Fran they
got truned by Baltimore but they had
played well all year against good teams
bad teams they had some injuries and had
a three- game losing streak but I think
they the confidence to know like all
right that was a bad game we're going to
go rebound and play well next week in
Washington and they did I think for
Miami to lose a game like that the way
they did against another good football
team I think it it it shocks him a
little bit and and you know stuns him
and punches him right in the face
because it's like all right last week we
got over this hump and now not only did
we lose we got blown out so now we got
to find another way to kind of get back
on our feet and go out there and play
against a team that's really hungry to
proed that they had this really bad
stretch and everyone thought they were
done and now here they are with a chance
to getting the playoffs and nobody would
want to play Josh Allen and the bills in
the playoffs when you rest in week 18 I
mean It's tricky because you don't want
somebody to get hurt but you also kind
of want to keep that momentum or have
that playoff mentality so if you're the
Ravens they may not play Lamar Jackson I
don't know if uh the Cowboys are going
to have everybody play the 49ers have
everybody play you have been in that
situation before what what's it like
with the team when not everybody is
playing yeah I've never had to make that
decision as a coach but I think from a
player standpoint the games and the
teams that I've been on when we said hey
we're going in and we're playing and
sometimes we played a half sometimes we
played the whole game we didn't know
that we just stayed focused on playing
the game I think that's the best way to
do it I think if you sit out this week
then you sit out next week that now
turns into two weeks where you don't
have a game plan because trust me if
guys aren't playing they're not going
home studying their game plan watching
film like they're taking a week off so
you take two weeks off I think you kind
of get out of the flow of football so to
me if you have guys that are banged up
like Christian mcaffrey you know kind of
strained his C like yeah you rest him
but guys that are healthy I would tell
them hey we're going out there playing
and we're going to put our best foot
forward and continue to do what we've
done like Baltimore they've looked great
the last two weeks I don't know if you
want to sit everybody and take that risk
Gerard May used to tell me all the time
football's 100% injury rate so no matter
what you can't just say don't play guys
because I'm worried about getting
injured like we all sign up to go play
football go play football do you think
Tom Brady was serious about coming out
of retirement in this past
may I mean you can't say he wasn't like
why wouldn't he I mean and then we
watched all of the quarterbacks that got
hurt this year and we watched the play
of it I mean he would have been right he
would be T he'd be top what five in the
NFL right now at quarterback if he was
still playing so I don't put it past him
well nobody wants to retire like I
right we all wish we could keep going
yeah because I don't know if uh he wants
to do the broadcasting I mean maybe he
does I have you talked to
him I I've never asked him but I know
people are around him um what you know
he's doing the podcast and different
things now they believe that he does
they said he he he's studying he's
preparing they believe he does want to
get out there and give broadcasting a
shot Explain the ending on the Cowboys
Lions
game I think it was simple the lion Drew
up a play no matter how like me and
Chris Sims were talking about it he
feels like you shouldn't be able to kind
of you know go against the spirit of a
rule and I'm like no like it's if it's
within the rules you should be able to
do it and to me the lines Drew up a
great play and a key situation and I
don't know exactly how was it explain
for Brad Allen and the crew to
understand the play that was coming up
but I thought it was simple the the
officials they kind of blew it you know
they didn't take time it was a two-point
play so there's no rush they didn't take
time to listen and figure out all right
this guy's report eligible Dan Skipper
had come in time after time in that game
and the officials watch film he's been
that guy all year coming in heavy tight
end I'm eligible and they just assume
and it was just it was a human era and
that doesn't make Detroit or Dan happy
but I think that's what it was and I
think it would have been a lot easier at
the end of the day to say hey this call
and this situation should have been
handled better obviously it was
confusing but we need to get this right
that's our job to get it right and we
didn't and it is what it is okay but as
a defensive player the the referee comes
and tells the entire defense that you
know 70 is is
eligible yep and I've been in games we
played the Colts one year and Blake
castanza caught a touchdown playing the
The Identical play playing left tackle
and we felt like the official didn't
tell us who was eligible because the
game's going fast everything they rush
to the ball like that's a part of the
game and if you've played defense you've
been in situations where you're like no
one told us or we missed it like that's
what happens in key parts of the game
and that's why offensive coordinators
wait to pull that out in a play that
they really need in an intense part of
the game I'm talking to Devin mccordi
works for football night in America w
three Super Bowls with the Patriots and
their game coming up this weekend it'll
be the bills and the Dolphins the final
game of the regular season how much
better are the ners and Ravens if I gave
you the ners and Ravens or the rest of
the field to win the Super
Bowl I I would take those guys by right
now I would say a pretty long shot I
think once you get in the playoffs and
you know how it works out that can
change but I think from just watching
the games have they've kind of come
about these two teams all season have
been you know two of the better teams
and I think this you know last few games
of the regular season they've kicked it
up a notch to really try to go in a
playoff form so um I don't really think
anybody uh in those two divisions are
close I say those two conferences I mean
are close to you know Baltimore and San
Francisco what's wrong with the
Eagles confidence I I think you know we
always talk about this Swagger or like
trying to you know live up to and it
comes from doing something day in and
day out and this team from the beginning
of the Season hasn't been able to be in
the form that they want and early in the
season they continued to say we got to
keep getting better we're going to keep
progressing and then it got to a point
where it was like all right we keep
waiting and it's not happening and I
feel like now you can feel just the the
animosity the tension on the sideline
they beat the Giants last week I don't
know what Devonte Smith and serani talk
about on the sideline but they're
wrapping the game up and these two are
going back and forth do you see AJ Brown
frustrated this week you know they
whatever you want to call what they did
with Desi him going upstairs Matt
Patricia coming down and calling a
defense that's not his defense is a very
abnormal task to put on a person hey I
know you don't run this defense
naturally but call it so it just seems
like they've been searching and they
haven't found it um and we've been
waiting to see can they get one win that
kind of gets him going and then to go
lose this past week seems like that
could be uh the end of the Philadelphia
Eagles this year all right I'm going to
let you have the floor to talk about
ruer
football what a doozy it was I was at
the game Yankee Stadium against the U to
see all of the U the starter throwback
starter jackets um Ruckers goes gets a
huge win I know the bows aren't what
they used to be but Vince Wolford didn't
like my text message he kind of
dismissed me you know it's a great you
he used to tell me all of the story so I
just wanted to let him know that we beat
you know we beat up on his team his Alma
but he didn't want to hear it but uh the
future looks really bright uh at pasato
New Jersey wait let's not get carried
away there let's not get carried away
you know pinstrip bull I mean come on
it's not it's not take our way where we
can get them maybe next year but was
that your biggest offer
ruers it was it was actually my only uh
I don't know what it's called now but at
the time division 1 a offer was Ruckers
that was the only one I had
wow you're not bitter are you did you
well that probably you play with the
chip do you still have a chip on your
shoulder oh well for one kiano and
Ruckers didn't want to offer me my
brother was the better player coming out
of high school they only offered me
because my mom I ended up finding this
out uh probably a few months ago that my
mom went into oano it's a package deal
you can't get one without the other so
that's the only reason they mom just
told you she went behind our back Mom
didn't tell us Darren Rizzy special
teams coach for the Saints who recruited
us to Ruckers at the time was with my
brother when my brother called a Saints
game and he told him that story and I I
told shano after when we spoke to
Ruckers and in Boston College wouldn't
offer me so I've always had a little
chip on my shoulder uh that so many
schools decided that I just wasn't good
enough uh definitely push me out my
whole career you don't mess with
Mom yeah my mom knows and she made sure
not to tell me cuz she knew I wouldn't
have went if if I knew they she told him
that so she kept it a secret all this
time uh great to talk to you and have
fun on Sunday night thank you again
Devin no problem man I appreciate you
having me that's Devon mccorney prid of
ruter University